Elon Musk has said he wants to create a
ride-sharing network of semi autonomous
Tesla's but it would still be based on
ownership these would be cars that
people still own and you disagree with
his vision y-yeah disagree because
there's a lot of benefits to kind of the
the large fleet operations that lyft
already does so imagine I think the best
way of understand the consumers
perspective so consumer in the future we
believe just like they pay for Netflix
or Spotify will pay for a monthly
subscription to transportation we'll be
able to take care of all your parking
all your fuelling all your cleaning and
maintenance you won't have to worry
about that at all and you'll get a
consistent experience you could choose
from the family lift service the
business lift ride whatever experience
you want we're going to be able to offer
you without all those hassles in a world
where you have private ownership you're
not going to have a consistent
experience that one's going to have less
stuff in their car and cars won't be
available at the times they're most
needed in the peak commute times